hi i'm jennifer evans cario the
president of sugar spun marketing the
author of pinterest marketing an hour a
day and the social media faculty chair
at market motive thanks for joining me
for part one in our series on
foundations of social media
when we look at social media and what it
is and understanding how it works it's
important to know that at its core it's
really just about people connecting with
other people it's also about people
connecting with businesses with
organizations with brands but ultimately
connections are what's at the core of
social media sharing thoughts sharing
resources sharing media sharing ideas
it's really about having a place where
people can come together to spread those
things around
it also represents an enormous market
for businesses and for organizations
when you look at a site like facebook
having well over a billion monthly users
and continuing to grow or a service like
youtube that serves over a billion
people every single day
when we look at twitter
linkedin instagram pinterest and a
variety of other popular social channels
we're looking at hundreds of millions of
people coming together in all sorts of
different environments to share
information and connect with each other
social media also has the potential to
impact virtually every area of your
business whether it's upper management
participating in things like thought
leadership and blogging and
conversations across social channels or
it's the more obvious form of your
marketing team and your public relations
team participating in getting the type
of branding and messages out there while
also recruiting the evangelists and the
influencers who will help carry your
message out to the greater populace even
when we look at the sales and hr side
there's plenty of opportunity here for
your sales team to leverage it to make
new connections and for your hr team to
use it to bring new employees in to vet
employees or contractors and to have a
greater understanding of the decisions
they're making to impact your business
even when we look at things like product
development and customer service there's
the potential to look into the realm of
social media to gather feedback and
input and ideas that can change the way
you do business
social media has the potential for small
companies and for new companies to bring
credibility and to bring it at a much
faster pace because when someone
discovers a new brand and they can
immediately read things like reviews and
insight that other customers have had
dealing with that same company makes it
much easier for them to make a decision
about whether or not this brand that's
new to them is one that they'd like to
engage with
on the flip side it gives big businesses
and established brands the chance to
change the perception to change the
personality around that brand so when a
company like old spice has long been
known as being the aftershave that your
grandfather your great-grandfather might
use
turned to social media in an effort to
connect with a new audience in a new
demographic they were able to see a
massive sales increase as an entire new
generation started viewing them in a
completely different way
social media gives you the ability to
have unparalleled insight into your
target audience what do they think what
are they sharing what makes them take
action so it's understanding that for
one company it might be about
gamification and facebook sharing and
likes and for a completely different
company it might be about digging deep
in something like linkedin or an
industry forum to really have a strong
conversation with someone but ultimately
knowing what makes your target audience
take action is extremely important to
figuring out how you're actually going
to get out there and reach that target
audience